das ticker also hier ist der mister
duisburger christa schicken ich
überhaupt nicht so etwas frischen
ich setze große hoffnungen in die
chicken sandwich persönlich für mich
nicht nur die kleinen wenn du den ganzen
bürger mit recht ist es gut gedacht die
box öffnen zum abend allerdings die wenn
der ganze karton zugeklebt ist die
sorgen jetzt nicht also wirklich so sehr
sehr sorge mister bis der könig von
youtube kann man wirklich nicht anders
sagen kein anderer youtube hat glaube
ich so ein starkes wachstum hingelegt in
den letzten jahren und macht so kranke
videos falls ihn jemand nicht kennt der
typ nimmt quasi alle seine einnahmen und
knallt sie raus er hat letztes zum
beispiel ein video gedreht für
dreieinhalb millionen dollar squibb bms
hat haben ganz viele von euch gesehen
und die 50 millionen aufrufe nach einem
tag aber was vielleicht nicht jeder vor
nicht weiß mister dies hat auch eine
eigene burger kette und zwar über nacht
in ganz amerika es gibt verschiedene
restaurants die sich bewerben können und
die dann quasi produkte beziehen von
mister bis und mit diesem produkt neben
die kreation von mystery ist überall
verkauft geniales konzept kenne ich
überhaupt nicht macht auch keinen sinn
update vom in friends of business
eigentlich aber das hat so voll wird das
sehen wir wenn jetzt jemand an der seite
rein schauen das ist ganz viele
verschiedene versionen quasi ihren
zubereitungs standards gibt bei burger
wenn wir zum beispiel schon der nächste
wiesberger dir zu unserem modell
3,75 an seiner stelle wäre ich nicht
happy wenn mein eigenes baby mein
restaurant mit einem 3,7 bewertet werden
wenn wir was zu mehr standorten gehen
sind wir schon mal 3,94 vermacht 539
wieder 4,8 die habe ich gesehen dass mir
fairerweise wäre das auch so gut
schmeckt wie es gibt da stelle ich dort
und ich habe eine bestellung abgeschickt
und hier oben seht ihr meine bestellung
chocolate chip cookie
249 den kristall burger mit pommes ist
auch national hot schicken tenders
sandwich weil ich schon die ganze messen
so national hot schicken und die biester
bürger kommen mit dem peace prize der
christ reitberger ist möglicherweise
nach christi nannte er eine große rolle
auf mussawis channel spielt und wir
gucken uns das ganze jetzt mal ab auch
das packaging macht absolut sinn von
ghost kitchen perspektive also von so
einem lizenz restaurant einfach sticker
drauf hier unten der nationalität wir
machen das jetzt einmal auch wenn die
sunrise sieht man hier auch welche nicht
wirklich überraschend fair finde also
wir sind hier in miami hier kostet alles
unendlich viel geld wir mit insgesamt 3
berger ein getränk einmal pommes und
cookies für 32 dollar und es wäre
wirklich schön und gut dass das so
günstig war aber in deutschland hier bei
uns hätte es noch günstiger sein wenn
nämlich aus einem bestimmten grund
aufgrund meines partners igraal igraal
ist nämlich eine cashback plattform bei
der man einfach dafür dass man sie nutzt
geld zurückbekommt das funktioniert so
greift von partnershops eine provision
dafür dass ist man über igraal kauft
also beispielsweise wie kriegen 10 euro
von einem schule nicht mehr kaufe und
die geben diese provision bis zu 90
prozent weiter an euch mit anderen
worten win win situationen und das
funktioniert auch bei essen nicht nur
beim essen sondern weil über 1800
weiteren partnershops expedia media
markt und so weiter und so fort und das
ganze funktioniert nicht nur in der
igraal iphone app oder android app
sondern auch in der browser erweiterung
ich zeige euch das ganze jetzt arbeit
hier in der igraal app lieferando
cashback aktivieren 3 prozent cashback
ist aktiviert habt dann gehe ich hier
meine adresse ein nur um es euch mal zu
zeigen die clique jetzt hier zum
beispiel auch prinz sie suchen ein paar
sachen aus jetzt hätten wir zum beispiel
28 eur 80 im warenkorb und so einfach
hätten wir dann auch schon 85 cent
gespart also ist wirklich so leicht dass
wir dann nach ein paar tagen
freigeschaltet und es gibt quasi keinen
grund das ganze nicht zu nutzen weil man
spart einfach da wo man sonst nicht
gespart hätte so ich weiß auch dass
irgendwie selbsterklärend so und das
beste bevor es jetzt weitergeht ich
krieg statt 5 euro startguthaben zehn
euro wenn ihr meinen link benutzt er ist
ganz oben verlinkt also probiert es aus
mit euch alles gibt wirklich nichts zu
verlieren danke für die unterstützung an
egal und weiter mit dem video jedem vers
reingucken hier sieht es darin aus ich
weiß es gar nicht okay sind sind schon
mal mehrere jobs chip cookies ich frag
mal alles aus ist
man merkt auf jeden fall dass minister
wies am werk war es das ultra flash von
den farben hier alles auch bekannt für
seine paar mails mit ricola noch dazu
dann haben wir eigentlich nur noch eine
handvoll verschiedener saucen dips
gleich schon mal ist es glaube ich eine
box ja die ist nur unterschiedlich viel
befüllt aber wir haben alle verschiedene
sticker also hier ist der mister
wiesberger hier sind die bees preis
christa und schicken wir packen jetzt
zuallererst den klassischen mister
bieten bürger aus ich muss mich sagen
ich bin großer fan und ich habe mich in
deutschland schon immer mal gefragt wie
schmeckt das ganze so was wie
funktioniert dieses große chance'
prinzip so ist das sinnvoll das lecker
und hier haben wir etwas was uns
hoffentlich die antwort liefert warum
sieht wirklich den chips nun waren für
so eingelieferten bürger das erste was
wirklich auffällt ist natürlich das
aussehen es sieht sehr gut aus aber dann
ist es das brot und das brot ist
überhaupt nicht so etwas geschieht so
wie man das kennt man es ist relativ
mäßig relativ schwer relativ hart bin
gespannt wie sich das auf einen burger
aus wirklich selbst bevorzuge eigentlich
immer wenn die brote so verschmelzen
sollte barrios sparen offensichtlich
keinen gefühls mal selbst zur genug
geredet wir probieren das
[Musik]
bunnefeld überhaupt nicht negativ auch
gar nicht man denkt man denke ich dass
es hart dass vielleicht ein bisschen alt
oder so wochen- oder trocken genau aber
es wird einfach so richtet juli
also ich muss wirklich sagen ist auf
jeden fall schon mal besser als jeder
bürger zum beispiel bei merkel und das
ist eine ansage main die machen und
nicht erst seit gestern war so genannte
auch in der er schmeckt richtig gut
man sieht auf jeden fall dass es nicht
mehr um ray oder so er ist komplett
durchgebracht eines mörders ist direkt
leidet das wirklich genug soße dabei ist
genug etlichen geil karamellisiert und
behielt diese wirken mag ist auch
bedient ich finds geil grad mit der
kombination mit den fans und haben das
brot ist stabil wie du sagtest said
natürlich besser als jeder messbare aber
ich bin auch abgesehen davon auch besser
als manch ein sogenannter premium bürger
mehr auf martina feldt bei unserem
deutschland sowieso nach diesem bürger
würde ich sagen was geht sehr stark
qualitativ und vom geschmack berechnung
fließt das war also der piesberger der
namensgebende berger wir müssen jetzt
einfach alles andere noch aus hessen
aber ein bisschen im schnelldurchlauf
einfach weiß auch selbst neugierig bin
hier haben wir die die style preis haben
sind die nicht eigentlich am kiesteich
kosten extra sind sie nicht mehr okay
das natürlich jetzt flott es gibt
nämlich die sogenannten biest style
preis dass sie noch mal so gut
bestückten dabei und so wir haben auf
irgendeinem grund ganz normale bekommen
deshalb keine ahnung weiß ich nicht
vielleicht einmal eine größere portion
so die gurken sind auf jeden fall nicht
am start wir probieren aber ich merke
schon beim anfassen
scheiße
ist es gut gedacht die box mit
eröffnungsabend machte so viel wenn der
ganze karton zugeklebt ist aber das ist
halt irgendwie so ein ding
wahrscheinlich vorschrift sich die wie
auch immer die taugen jetzt nichts also
die sind wirklich so sehr sehr
es muss auch nicht alles okay hier sind
schlecht so wie sie ankommen sie haben
dann haben die nette würzung die
freising kleiner reinfall leider deshalb
trifft sich sehr gut dass wir auf dem
kristall denn hier habe auch gomez drauf
haben aber auch
amazon wie sie so sind wie ich habe
diesmal in brega spannt schäfer vor die
pommes sollen falls ich so sein sollen
feier ist auf jeden fall nicht so sehr
aber neue chance auf der oberseite keine
source zumindest und der seite kriegen
wir nicht gelöst man muss hier nur
durchsagen kommen wie klein das petit
ist wenn du den ganzen bürger material
sollte hätten wir das nicht gemacht oder
das war bei dem anderen gerade nicht so
aber probier mehr
[Musik]
trocken ja gar keiner so drauf
vielleicht mag der chris halt keine
chance kann ja sein leben wir können uns
jetzt auf keinen fall angreifen wenn er
keine soße drauf ist wenn der bürger so
ist noch frisch wie peggy sue daraus
ziehen mögen kiesbänken tochscreen
gefräst also er hat einfach keine soße
dieser bürger ist persönlich für mich
nichts aber was man sagen muss das sind
keine smash party spa sind half way
specialities die habe ich einfach
wahrscheinlich so diese bietet leider
oder diese kugeln die haben genommen und
nicht richtig unter dass menschen und
das ist halt das ding wenn du kaufst
kitsches macht obwohl das die am besten
bewertete in der gesamten umgebung ist
also ihr seht schon wie dick das hier
ist das fleisch mehr mittel
geschmacklich ist das auch vollkommen
okay aber die kreation ist sich malz und
die ausführungen hier ist auch nicht
wirklich so es wäre ja nicht schlimm
wenn das fleisch wenigstens dann den
gruß mitbringen würde ja das ist keine
show auch wenn man jetzt presst da kommt
ja gar kein glück mehr aus dass er
wirklich nicht glauben smart ja also an
diesem bürger war wirklich nur der bacon
wirklich geil oder war krasser und
besser als ich ihn häufig gegessen habe
auf bürgern so das kann man auf jeden
fall vorher aber ansonsten war der
eigentliche enttäuschung und
zwischenfazit zwei von drei sachen waren
eher enttäuschend ist muss ich sagen
weil ich habe wirklich viel erwartet
immer wenn ich sowieso wie darüber
gesprochen habe war ich so richtig halte
ich dachte das muss sie ausprobiert
logischerweise sagte das ist ja geil es
aber es gibt wirklich diese letzte
sachen die wir haben das national hot
chicken sandwich will ich schon lange
probieren sollte das immer auf meiner
seite und ich hoffe dass es nicht
scheiße umgesetzt ist weil das zerstört
und meinen traum soll und so ein geiles
bei chicken sandwich wir haben das
budget bahn das will man mehr ersten
beraten was wir gut war also optisch auf
jeden fall auf platz eins gemeinsam mit
dem mister wiesberger würde ich sagen
weil da sieht man ein bisschen was dabei
so da sind die sogar ein pickel salat
als tomatenketchup dass mario und diese
chicken peace ist sehen budget aus
willich sagen die sich gut aus das auf
spies mix um daraus könnte auf jeden
fall scharf sein und ich setze große
hoffnung in die chicken sandwich
enttäuschen
[Musik]
vor genau das wollte ich zeigen mit
danke
das erste in dieser bestellung was krank
und haben wir das vorhaben hörbar
knuspriger panade dezenten spies was ich
aber nachvollziehen kann das ist eine
super scharf machen das ist geil und das
habe ich auch mein favorit das so ein
bisschen besser als cathy chicken
sandwich ist was jetzt auch keine
erleuchtung ist aber dafür dass man das
fahrzeug über nacht aus dem boden
stampft schon sehr stark der letzte
bestandteil unserer bestellungen die
cookies die auf den ersten blick nicht
wahnsinnig überzeugend also diese nicht
wie subway cookies die so sichtbar soft
sind und die sind auch nicht software
hat gesehen wie ich den gebrochen habe
aber jetzt vielleicht auch gesehen dass
da zumindest flüssige schokolade drin zu
sein scheint die erwartungen sind hoch
ich probiere verdeckt man hat auf jeden
fall schonmal glücklichere max sehen
also es sind vielleicht schon ein
bisschen geiler supermarkt cookies wie
man auch bei uns in deutschland bekommt
und 3 spielt darf man für 250 so wir
feiern immer und so die liebe zum essen
merkt wenn man merkt dass leute
mit passionen dabei sind das kriegst du
nicht wenn du so ein groß kariertes ding
staates über nacht und das kriegst du
auch nicht wenn du vollkommen unbekannte
deine kreationen zubereiten ist mein
fazit zum wiesberger nichts was ich
jetzt jedem empfehlen würde ein zwei
burger sind auf jeden fall nicht so ist
flash einen leider nichts und die pommes
und wie scheiße das war es dann mit dem
video leute ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen auch wenn es heute leider nicht
ein durchweg positives video ward haben
wir auch schon länger ich mich aber auch
schon leute sehen ließ noch mal
beschwert haben es ja alles immer noch
kein ja aber ich mir mühe gebe euch die
möglichst geilsten dinge zu zeigen und
ich dachte auch hier das ist geiler ist
als es war nichtsdestotrotz hofft nicht
unterhaltsam gesehen zunächst mal wieder
geschafft
[Musik]